so I'm making guys what's up what's up
with Jaden Raj who ng sunrise is a great
artist from the years and I had the
chance to perform in front of him J'son
Raj J'son Russ so you performed with him
I performed in front of him he came to
he was watching you perform much this is
back before yeah you know Hong Kong when
I was not yet immersed in many force law
so it was a big honor for me because he
inspired me to be a musician an artist
and as soon as I became a still night
standing the Quran in the first year of
Ramadan and I just hope that you know I
was watching this video and hopefully
because I think is a great soul there's
a great spirit he's a seeker of truth so
I just hope I'll ask want I will guide
him like me you know so not too long
after Europe report used to be a
musician himself yeah I launched an
album I was touring around Asia event
playing reggae music funk music and
Jason Rhys was my inspiration
bommali Jason rice so when he came to my
concert I was a big thing for me you
came up you wrote a letter to all gave
it to him and he showed up he showed up
with his manager and he stayed the whole
set and we had a talk together and I me
encouraged me to do good and he said
we're in the same team so I just wanna
said to Jason we are still in the same
team but inshallah under the banner of
truth and which is the religion of Allah
Tala and there's no other way to be on
the path of truth so hopefully we'll be
guided and before some of his followers
can reach reach out to him and and you
know so he can watch this video and
start to
I mean a different way yeah yeah a lot
of misconceptions about Islam when you
say the religion of the creator of the
heavens and earth you figured out the
purpose of life so now we're trying to
get this to him and hopefully he'll
remember you it can be a catalyst for
him to really like start to because you
because usually when you're in that
lifestyle before we cut out yeah
is that there is no peace really I mean
of course I mean I was actually I wrote
a song about freedom in Hong Kong
because I was doing this concert and I
was I knew I was not upon freedom I was
looking for freedom and ask God in that
song or God showed me the light to be
free so it's literally my song free to
love and so I wrote that song right
after the concert right after meeting
Jason I was inspired to write asking for
guidance to God in Michelle after a few
years time he brought me to Islam that's
the key the key right there is to ask
your Creator alone no intermediaries for
guidance the one who created me guide me
you did that your upon this way of life
not hopefully what's his name Jason Russ
Jason Brown hopefully this gets to him
he lives in San Diego California
he's a baccardo a farmer as well he like
he loves organic food I mean he has a
lot of good in him you know it's the
only thing is very it was not informed
you know this is a true religion of God
and and and he talks about God in his
songs as well that's why I hope you will
make the final step me too
we'll see you soon hopefully with some
good news cheese and rice all right
peace salaam alaikum